SPEAKER 1: I'm a software
engineer born in Bulgaria.
SPEAKER 2: I'm an Android
developer based in Berlin.
SPEAKER 3: I'm a
Flutter developer.
SPEAKER 4: I am a web developer.
SPEAKER 5: I'm an Android
engineer from Hangzhou, China.
SPEAKER 6: I'm Anna
from GDG Bari.
SPEAKER 7: I'm from
Chicago, Illinois.
SPEAKER 8: I am from Lima, Peru.
SPEAKER 9: I am in
Denver, Colorado.
SPEAKER 7: Flutter has changed
the way I develop really
because of the fact that
I've never really developed
with a bird by my
side all the time.
SPEAKER 10: Flutter change a
lot of things in our lives.
First of all, it change
the way that we code.
SPEAKER 11: I fell
in love with Flutter
from the very first time I saw
Emily live-coding the meme chat
app on Google I/O.
SPEAKER 3: And what's great
is that Flutter is native.
SPEAKER 2: Me and my partner
built an app in a single day.
SPEAKER 12: Our
company currently
works on five Flutter projects.
SPEAKER 6: With
Flutter, I don't have
to go online and check
the docs anymore.
The way the framework
is structured
makes it easy to jump
into the definition
and learn new things.
SPEAKER 13: I
switched to Flutter
from JavaScript and PHP.
Having strictly typed code,
it's just a game changer.
SPEAKER 14: My favorite
part about Flutter
is that it does not
limit your imagination.
SPEAKER 12: I love
that with Flutter you
can edit the UI code
and simultaneously
preview the changes,
both on Android and iOS.
SPEAKER 15: The UI page
developed by Flutter
is very smooth, especially
on low-end machines.
SPEAKER 16: Flutter
has immensely
helped me with my
transportation application.
SPEAKER 6: This year we
decided to make our app
for the first interim factor.
SPEAKER 13: We're using
Flutter to rebuild
our native mobile apps.
We're going from three
code bases down to two.
SPEAKER 11: With Flutter,
it's been really, really easy
to bring my ideas to life.
SPEAKER 9: One of
the things I didn't
have any experience with
was mobile app development.
So I decided now is
as good a time as any.
I'm building my own mobile app,
and I'm doing it with Flutter.
SPEAKER 17: I have also
open sourced three Flutter
applications on GitHub.
SPEAKER 18: These animations are
entirely provided on Flutter.
SPEAKER 19: I like
widgets, and I
like how it allows me
to build apps quickly.
SPEAKER 20: You can
quickly turn your ideas
into real applications.
SPEAKER 4: I really like
the Firebase integration
because I usually use
Firebase for all my projects,
and it's super easy to
get started with Flutter.
SPEAKER 21: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER 11: I really, really
enjoy the community engagement
on Twitter, as
well as on GitHub.
SPEAKER 22: What took
us almost 16 months
to create an iOS app has
taken less than four months
in Flutter.
SPEAKER 2: One of my favorite
things about the Flutter
community is that you can find
examples about everything.
SPEAKER 23: My favorite
part about Flutter
is that it makes me
much more productive.
SPEAKER 7: The
thing that excites
me the most about Flutter
and the Flutter community has
to be the support from
the development team
and from the community
of developers.
SPEAKER 13: My favorite part
of Flutter is, without a doubt,
the amazing
productivity it enables.
We're accomplishing in months
what in the past took us years.
SPEAKER 24: Flutter
community is awesome.
I mean, I have never felt so
home in any other developer
community.
SPEAKER 1: With Flutter I
spend less time compiling,
and more time smiling.
SPEAKER 11: That is my
Flutter development story.
SPEAKER 9: That's
my Flutter story.
SPEAKER 7: And this
is my Flutter story.
SPEAKER 25: Flutter!
SPEAKER 26: Woo!
SPEAKER 19: Flutter.